Alright, everybody, welcome back. So, let's, let's work through these. Charles,
what is, what are you thinking for, for this first one.
>> I'm thinking I should write a program, and just
run it through, 'because that's the easiest thing to do.
>> So what you're saying is this f function is
so kind of wacky that it's hard to imagine actually analyzing
it, and doing anything with it. But, on the other
hand. The X, the space of X values is very small.
>> Right.
>> Good so right so we can
enumerate all the possible values and just
see which one gives the highest output.
>> Yeah that's pretty straight forward if I just wrote
the code, in fact it's like one line of code.
>> So I wrote it for you.
>> Oh good.
>> I'm nice that way.
>> You are nice that way, you optimized our time.
>> Our did, for what it's worth, this is what
the function looks like. I'm not even sure that's a function.
>> Isn't that beautiful?
>> It's something. It looks DNA gone wrong.
>> Yeah,
totally wrong, there's just mutations everywhere. It's like a bow
tie that then tried to hide itself in another dimension.
I mean like, you can see there's this interesting up
and down-ness to it like a, like the sine wave part.
>> Mm.
>> But they're, they're interdigitated with each
other. It's all, it's just crazy to me.
>> Interdigitated. That is an excellent word.
>> Yeah, it means, it means to put you're fingers together.
>> Hm.
>> So,
>> So what happens if you plot that but with,
connecting lines?
>> Oh, oh, hee, hee. Sure. [LAUGH]
>> Wow.
>> You get somethin' like that. Wow.
>> This is a kind of unfriendly function.
>> Yeah, this is not the friendliest function I have ever seen.
>> And now it looks a bit like, actually
it looks a bit like an insane bow tie.
>> Nice. Electric bow tie.
>> Yeah.
>> So it turns out that there's two points that
are really really close to the top. There's this one at
11 and there's this one I don't know a little bit after
80 or so. But the 1 and the 11 is actually the largest.
>> Hm. This function goes too loud.
>> [LAUGH] It does indeed. So, I'm going to say 11.
I wanted to make a crazy function that was the,
was the first thing that popped into my head. Actually
I did, the second one was a mod three at first.
>> Hm, well, it's an interesting thing,
right because if you tried to reason this
out, it would be very difficult to do. I mean, first off, mod isn't very
nicely you know, it's very easy, it's not very easy to deal
with algebraically in closed form but you can start reasoning and say,
well, the dominating factor is mod seven in the sense that you're
never going to be greater than six and of course the mod six
is never going to be greater than five so the best you
can get there is five and then you minus the sign, which is
going to be some small number so you can kind of pick
all the values that are going to give you something like. Five there,
and then whichever one has the smallest Sine, that's the one
you go for. I wonder if that would get you anywhere close
to the right answer. So, interesting that that's not quite true here
because 11 mod six is, no 11 mod six is five, right?
>> Hmm.
>> Squared is 25. Mod seven is four. Is that right?
>> Anyway.
>> Hm, okay.
>> let's do the second one.
>> Okay.
>> Alright so it turns out
that, again, 11 and 80 are really close but 11 is slightly larger and it's just
almost five, but not quite. Alright, so for the second problem, now we can't
use of enumerating because our X's constitute the entire space of the, reals.
>> So, there's like, 200 of them.
>> More.
So we need to do something else. And I think what you were pointing out to me is
that because this is a nice polynomial. We can
actually use calculus to figure out where the maximum is.
>> Right, just take the derivative and set it equal to 0.
>> So unfortunately, I made that a little harder
than than probably you'd appreciate. So the derivative would
be this, and setting it equal to 0 would
give us this equation, which unfortunately is a cubic.
>> Right.
>> So it should have three solutions.
Perhaps, and you could just check each of them.
But solving the cubic is sort of a pain.
>> Mm mm.
>> I guess I could have been a bit nicer.
>> You could have been.
>> Sorry.
>> But it all depends what you're optimizing.
>> So how would you go about solving this now?
>> I would go on Google and I look up how do you solve cubics.
>> [LAUGH] Sure, that's not a bad idea.
Any other things, because it is nice and smooth,
right? So let's, here, let's, let me actually find it for you. So
here's the function, and I just plotted a subrange of it, from minus
500 to 1000. You know you could ask, could it be that the
maximum is actually someplace outside this
range. You know how you'd answer that?
>> No. So because it's a fourth order
polynomial, like think of like a, a quadratic,
>> Yeah.
>> It's got the one bump in it, a cubic can have as much as you know
one up bump and one down bump. And a qua, and a quartic ca, a 4th
degree polynomial can have an up bump, a
down bump, an up bump and then back down.
>> M-hm.
>> So we're actually seeing all the activity here,
outside this range it just plumettes negatively. It, it
can't turn around and come back up again. So
because we can see the two bumps we are good.
>> OK.
>> And in this case, it looks like the
bump that we want is somewhere between 500 and
a 1000, somewhere in the 700 kind of zone and well so one thing we could do
because it's really well behaved, we can kind of
zoom in on the function at that range. Mm-hmm.
>> So there we are now zoomed in from between 500 and 1,000. We can see,
okay, well, actually it looks like the peak
is maybe between 600 and 800, you think?
>> I'd say 700 and 800.
>> Between 700 and 800. All right, well let's take a look at that.
>> Ooooo.
>> Nice and
Pointy. Alright. So how bout that?
>> 740. How bout 740 and 760?
>> So we really are kind of getting into
the nitty gritty here. So, so, for the
quiz we'll you know, we accepted anything, between
you know, 745 and 755. But in fact we
can keep zooming in and we can use calculus, and we can, we can really hone on
what that, the tippy top is there. But
that's not so important right now, we could also
something called Newton's method, you know Newton's method?
>> I remember it.
>> Newton, newton's method said if, you
know, guess a position like you know, 455
sorry 755, and use the derivative at that point which is actually really easy to
compute, doesn't involve solving the, the cubic,
it just involves, Writing down the cubic and
evaluating at that point, we can actually you
know, fit with the straight line is here.
And we can take it, take steps in the direction of
that line, it's a, it's a gradient ascend kind of method.
>> Yeah.
>> And, and that'll allow us to hone in, as we
get closer and closer to the top. The slope is going to flatten
out, we're going to take smaller steps And this process converges to
whatever the peak is, I think it's a little bit under 750.
>> That looks about right.